moving on to some debate club CEO
Brendan got a debate club for you last
night just got done watching that old
Brian Cowen claimed the fame hitter the
Joker on the big Batman fan I like the
Dark Knight so question is who's the
better Joker
Joaquin Phoenix or Heath Ledger let me
know gang gang bat butts ah man I don't
like it I've said this I don't like
where uh comic book movies are going
it's too realistic I don't that Joker
great movie that's it was so dark man
yeah I like that Jack Nicholson Joker I
like when it's a little pretend it's
doing real hmm I don't need Batman being
all realistic you know I like it fake
I like Mr Freeze chill out
I like Jim Carrey is the Riddler I'm
saying thank you I came to view as the
penguin yeah the best yes Michelle
Pfeiffer's Catwoman yeah yeah I couldn't
pretend Lynn this shit's too real man
I'll tell you what this is a pop weapon
y'all can suck my Stephan dick like I
like Jared Leto as the Joker I thought
he was dope as the Joker I haven't seen
many of this do you see the rocks oh I
saw the Joaquin Phoenix man I thought it
was amazing it's so it's a math thought
it was super smart the way that they
like went into the Joker was more
actually but yeah I guess if you're I'm
not a big fan of this type of stuff
where people you know change your
clothes and be like uh somebody who can
do all kind of amazing stuff all of a
sudden like but I like Batman be a
little more unrealistic like because
Batman doesn't really have any skills
just a rich dude right to fight right
and like pay some Morgan Freeman and
make all these ante [ __ ] he's basically
an easier rich who's the decent Antipa
before it went real dawg they went wait
laughs ah but I like I thought the I
haven't seen the Heath Ledger 1 you've
never seen is he good so good but but
he's barely in it like he's in it
he's not that much in it compared to
walking Phoenix who carried the whole
movie he was in a more than Jared Leto
and Suicide Squad here's a problem with
that Jared Leto said how much he was in
they could have they could have made a
whole movie just on him as the Joker but
they use piss they did it so much he's
barely in it shipping it way more and he
died though in it right no he didn't w
shooting it no no and who's the guy in
the lower middle that guy who is that
that's Stefan that's Jared Leto oh it is
I haven't seen that one a lot of people
confuse it with Tony Hinchcliffe too
Jack Nicholson wasn't bad either
tony is cliff loki antifa as well Wow no
probably more of a Stefan vibe there
than Joker yeah you've never seen Dark
Knight don't do that's literally my
favorite movie oh really
it's amazing I love to watch it I played
the video game the video games not that
great okay it's cool that's a video game
yeah Dark Knight's amazing yeah I gotta
watch it then but I thought the new
Joker was good uh but I I was happy that
it was heavy oh it's real heavy man and
Brian was in it for three seconds yeah
but I thought he had a good little idea
I thought he did a good job in it did
you think I mean he was like hey and
then they just kind of went on you know
yeah but I was here to talk to him more
I wish they would have talked about when
the man was shooting that I was in New
York shooting some something for Bravo
TV I was on watch what happens live with
Andy Cohen so he was shooting Joker then
and I was like oh dude and we were
literally where he was and where I was
where I'm in a block away goes meet me
for dinner so I gotta be in for dinner
and you know the little [ __ ] in the
movie small guy I get their minds at
dinner with the [ __ ] with the small
man to even tell me now hey oh and you
just let me just be cool be cool
I'm cool but should give me a heads up
dude yeah great guy though great guy
yeah wonderful best man right there look
and what
name's Harold Harold
literally the worst part about this is
someone else just like Liam Brendan's
out of his mind
someone has it saved as [ __ ] from
Chuck Lake yo-yo really nice Scottish
yeah you know a lot of Scottish people
are have this syndrome really yep why is
that I think it's just through they
rebellious mm-hmm it's like I'm not
being told [ __ ] you you know make sense
like it's at a molecular level do you
think all the small people hate on the
guy from my games are thrown because
he's kind of like their Lord and Savior
you know I'm saying like he takes if
you're gonna get a role he's gonna get
it like you can only have so many small
people in a movie you're gonna have the
dude from Game of Thrones yeah you know
it swears he has kids and his daughters
normal size
so like : Hanson she's [ __ ] six foot
tall that's wild man crazy huh my used
to have a man bus who was a mechanic and
he was married to a little person and
everybody was shocked we didn't know no
one had ever seen it before
because you're not really allowed to say
refer to them as midgets you know you
did but [ __ ] is also French word if
you go to France stay in America a whole
life dude yeah get out there do a
backflip in the [ __ ] Eiffel Tower
that's a mess car go and do a cartwheel
bro I've only been in Canada in Mexico
oh yeah you got to get out well I wanna
go to Jamaica brah quit [ __ ] around
dude
go to go to the [ __ ] Thailand go to
one of the suck bars yeah I wouldn't you
a suck bar well you get a nice cold beer
and get sucked off under the table oh
hey 25:17
bro I have old duels for this and you
could fake the funk no you can just get
a bear
drink it look here fro ders dude that is
the worst idea to go all the way
somewhere just to get sucked off for a
nickel somewhere well go see a site and
do something but also go to the Sun go
to a tombstone or something you know go
do something special man you go to see
Allen see Bruce Lee's grave hey you got
I've seen Cobain
you go to Amsterdam see oh you could see
Jim Morrison's grave dude I did like
that about the Batman when he was in
like the underground cave and he had the
old man who was helping him out which
one was that Alfred Alfred yeah I like
that one was that an Amsterdam no no
that's what I'm not sure what movie that
was who was in it that was dark shadows
or what's called the first Batman I mean
the Batcave and Alfred were in every
Batman but Michael you know it'd be the
shittiest Batman ever would be Tom
Arnold horrible to watch who who's the
worst Batman Val Kilmer no oh that's
your boy I like to see those are my
favorite Batman Returns although those
are my Batman yeah this new [ __ ] did Ben
Affleck play him yeah okay I've Ben
Affleck played him that one kind of went
on to the Rutgers Batman vs Superman
yeah Ben Affleck was that juicy badly
was he his Batman on them and that deca
D ball Batman oh damn yeah he got real
juicy might have to get a sack of that
yeah the best one was the animated
series yes the car it was like more
serious was the best it was like mid 90s
it was really dark kind of serious it
was awesome yes I think that's what I
saw mmm honestly when you said it that's
the one I thought you the bald Alfred
that guy was cool was it Alfred Morgan
Freeman and one of them yeah no no that
was a Lucius Fox in Dark Knight he was
like the movie Dark Knight Michael Caine
was Alfred in Dark Knight
but yes take it easy was good Mark
Hamill as Joker was amazing to Mark
Hamill to send up the swim original uh
he was the one who did the animated
series oh right now it's time for a real
we also a stamp or a black Batman I feel
like you know do it then we're gonna do
black spider-man Donald Glover was gonna
be spider-man really yeah baby come on
they were like now we don't a black
spider-man but then they did the what's
named my rice who's the kid - Miles
Morales verse spider-verse which is the
best the best and the second ones coming
out next year and is it animated yeah
it's animated it's intimate it's so good
though I got on it you might send what
to the theater seven times the ones you
know Wow I know and we bought the
spider-man shoes Oh some spider-man
Jordan ones although he wore in spider
purse giddyup man is giddy up
[Music]
the King Mustang
[Music]